it is unbelievably easy for children to
come across pornography
by accident if you don't believe me try
googling the kind of innocent word
a child might search and see what comes
up the average age of children looking
at porn online
is 11. some studies put it at nine
it's linked to a six-fold rise in
aggressive sexual behavior
and growing levels of addiction the
younger a child is when they see porn
the more it affects the development of
their brain
these are all reasons why we need
regulation
for more than a year the government has
been working on a new system of age
verification
that would require users of online porn
to prove they are old enough to watch it
its launch has been delayed several
times because there are real concerns
about privacy
but under the proposed changes a
nine-year-old without a credit card
driving license or other verification
material would be less likely to stumble
across hardcore porn
and less likely to be able to access it
even if they try
and that has to be a good thing
[Music]
i actually agree with you on this okay
because like i say the internet for all
its great values and the brilliant
things it brings to the earth
it also brings a lot of honking this as
well okay and it does doesn't it because
it does it unlocks all this stuff to
your kids who
they would never see it you know unless
they found your stash under your pillow
for those of you that remember that sort
of thing
um that that that was the only way you
stumbled across it
okay so
anyway so but all i'm gonna say is with
the internet the way isn't kids the way
they are
today all right for every [ __ ] block
there is an unlock
all right so have a look at this at the
post office so you go and visit the the
adult website
when you do you'll be greeted with a
request to prove your age
going to a news agent like a pay point
buying a voucher that will look
something like this that will contain a
number
on it a unique number once you've used
it you can throw it away
that is your proof of age download the
ports app
and and scan the code onto your device
and then once you've done that
you simply scan the the request to prove
your age
it'll check the device and you're done
there you go
is that meant to sell it okay wendy
don't don't don't ask me how i knew this
information all right okay
but that's the sort of thing so for all
the for all the stuff that we put into
to mitigate that kids would always find
a way around anyway do you know what i
mean i think what we've got to do is try
and find a way of controlling
times that kids are allowed on the
internet watching what they're actually
doing and policing them properly i'll
tell you what the control
sorry i was just going to say just
before i bring everyone else in i just
want to show this this is a genuinely
effective way of putting kids off
watching porn
have their mums make it for them have a
look at this
it has never been easier for young
people to access porn that is after two
clicks
if my son ever treated a woman like that
yeah i would
kick his ass to kingdom come five
concerned mums come together to tackle
the porn industry we're gonna make a toy
film
we are porn producers and explore what's
hot
and what most definitely is not
that it's wrong these moms want to make
something new anything that's healthy
and loving i'm not going to do it it's
the film about sex the husband's going
to be restrained when i get home
that that will put them off won't
do you know what it's called parents
what are parents
the ages you quoted 11 no 15 14
i get it a nine-year-old having
unfiltered unrestricted access to
where is mum and or dad making sure what
they're doing and then i would argue in
an 11 year old
that's the control you need a mum or a
dad who's interested
but we've had this conversation before i
think we agree on the need to be very
circumspect about letting kids have
access unfettered access to devices
and always supervising them but do you
know how
easy it is they are one or two clicks
away
so they're doing it in the living room
so but they you don't want them to get
it
and see it for you to have to take it
away you don't want them to even get to
the point where they're seeing it and
it's not like a child needs to be left
alone for two hours
looking at porn websites otherwise they
can just post
every week for a paypal slip done if you
think this
if you think what's happening in this
world is unacceptable
why do you object so much to regulation
i don't think it'll work
and the regulation is with parents yeah
no then i think then i think there is an
argument
because it would be interesting to know
does it work and how can you make it
work but surely
uh no i think the next decade of
above the internet is going to be all
about regulation i think in so many
areas it's it's
it was a free force that suddenly there
are certain things happening that we
don't like and
therefore society is going to regulate
it it's it's interesting this this
block this um this new law that is is
going to come in which hasn't yet this
was launched off the back of an
an nspcc report um
and then which and and the result was
the children stumbled across it the
irony is
it's it's it's much easier to stumble
across porn
on social media sites like twitter and
reddit but this new law will this new
block will not cover
any of those sites and and that survey
that that
that um set the legislation in motion
was commissioned by a creative
market research group called one pal
that that that pays people to fill in
online questionnaires so it's important
to understand
this was put out people were paid kids
were paid to do this and
so they based the whole of that
legislation on this
which is not proper research it's not
it's not
informed research it's it's a it's a
question is it true
it's true that that research was
affected but the this is not actually
what launches those entire legislations
based on one piece of research there has
been
there have been numerous reports
commissions different organizations look
at this there have been criminal trials
of rape in the playground that have
massively informed public and political
opinion on this here this is what um a
poll of parents found
this is from internet matters not one
power of the 83 percent of parents of
children age 4 to 16 support age
verification
on commercial porn sites i'm not saying
that this these are mutually exclusive
either parents have a role or there
should be regulation we need both
but there has not been effective
regulation you're right this system is
massively flawed
do you know what i think as well when
you when you think about it if you if
you know just take an analogy if you've
got a bouncer outside a pub stopping
kids from coming in
what you don't get is more kids going
home to do homework you get kids getting
fake id's and drinking in the dark and
that's what that's what will happen here
kids
will get to the dark web somehow they
won't they won't
access the porn they can stumble across
on on the internet they will go to the
doctors
and they will be able to access stuff
they would never have gotten at nine
years old you've got no business
knowing what that does other than to pay
for it and that's why
i mean seriously kids should not be
exposed at that age and if they're
across legislation who should be
absolutely
bailing them down and saying no taking
away the smartphones not letting them
have access to internet unsupervised all
that sort of stuff
that's where it stops but surely the
kids are the most vulnerable
those whose parents are not going to do
that and that's why we need regulation
it's still that i and we've explored it
i just don't think i just don't see how
it will work isn't there
isn't there a better way that you come
in this and i don't you'll probably
speak more to your world
that we have a system whereby if these
companies are putting out this kind of
material they pay some kind of fine as
their way of looking
so instead of becoming it's more the
supplier and than the user end you see
what i'm saying is that something that
could be explored
yeah i i think the principle of
penalizing the producer rather than the
consumer is always
it always seems like a fairer approach i
mean the problem here is i'm not really
defending this
particular age verification because it
is really flawed like you said social
media gets around it you can use vpns to
get around
having the user details and the taste
preferences of millions of poor news
that's
and that's a hack waiting time remember
that thing that actually matters in the
canadian dating agency which supplied
dates for married
and people in relationships they've had
to pay out 11 million dollars in
compensation
to 33 million people because careers and
relationships were imagine what would
happen here but this is really true
that's one reason we haven't had
regulation the poor industry is
incredibly unwieldy it's difficult to
regulate millions of providers all over
the world
you know i i hear what you're saying
carol but the idea that if you regulate
things you drive them underground
is a reason for not regulating anything
that is always a consequence of trying
to regulate something
but one of the problems here one of the
problems here is the children who aren't
even
looking for porn being exposed to it now
this would at least help with that
because yeah it's going to make it
harder to stumble across my accent
that's that's not the whole problem
almost like i don't know almost like a
library or something like that so phil
this weekend you'll have to actually
join the sites that you use and they'll
have to verify
can't it be like that i get that i get
that but you know that that's so that
that thing at the post office that yeah
that you can bypass stuff like that by
doing you know i mean the kids will
always find a way if they want to
the argument i've got is they shouldn't
be stumbling on it that you're right
that's that's the point
i mean i i go on sites to hire a car
right yeah there's no one
obviously you have to be versatile
there's no way a child is going to be
able to hire a car
with hurts or avis or alamo or dollar
unless that's there must be a way of
doing this because it can't
a kid's never gonna they're never gonna
let it happen there must be a way where
these responsible suppliers
of not possible they're not all well
then find them but they're not how do
you find
an uh some underground website based in
there's millions of them
singapore you know it's very difficult
to control it's not like car
car rentals
we can't find them because we can't find
them is that right on google or facebook
it's
you know it's hard to identify someone
by their behavior
but with this system you're going to
have to put in your real name your real
email and your credit card details
dangerous so dangerous but but do you
think
i mean the question is this system might
not work
it could be the no systems work but do
you think we should be looking to do
something
god yes yes this piece of legislation is
not the answer this is a flawed piece of
legislation
i think we will agree to something he's
doing okay and i think me and nick
definitely agreed
the buck starts with the parents yeah
they're the ones who should be
controlled
and i just need to control myself we can
all agree nick has no idea how online
paul works
okay